Jake:我也不懂
Jake: I don't get it either.
Jake:这是北欧小朋友们捐赠的
Jake: This was donated by kids from Northern Europe.
Lucia: 真不知道该说他太太先进
Lucia: Really don't know whether to say it's too advanced
Lucia: 还是太落后呢
Lucia: or too backward.
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 直接倒就
Shure: Just pour it directly.
Shure: 倒了一点醋
Shure: Poured a bit of vinegar.
Jake:有用吗
Jake: Is it working?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: Don't know.
Lucia: 还在测试状态
Lucia: Still in testing mode.
Jake:我先自己转化一点
Jake: I'll convert a bit myself first.
Lucia: test     testing
Lucia: Test, testing.
Shure: 怎么样
Shure: How's it?
Jake:不到啊
Jake: Not there yet.
Shure: 评价一下吧
Shure: Give it a review.
Jake:过期教程
Jake: Outdated tutorial.
Jake:娃哈哈
Jake: Wahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我刚准备偷偷喝一瓶
Lucia: Hahaha, I was just about to sneak a drink.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia: 那既然被你发现了的话你要喝一瓶吗
Lucia: Since you found out, do you want to drink a bottle?
Jake:哈哈哈可以喝一瓶
Jake: Hahaha, can drink a bottle.
Alice:感觉跟冲的还是不一样
Alice: Feels different from the mixed one.
Alice:比它好喝
Alice: Tastes better.
Lucia: 发现楼上没有那个啥了
Lucia: I noticed that there's no more of that upstairs.
Alice:但是你喜欢酸的吗
Alice: But do you like sour things?
Jake:没喝的
Jake: No drinks.
Lucia: 对有酒但是现在不太能喝
Lucia: Right, there's alcohol but we can't drink it now.
Jake:好啊你现在不能喝
Jake: Okay, you can't drink now.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 年轻
Lucia: Young.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 没破吧没有
Lucia: Is it broken? No, it's not.
Lucia: 那我喝我把这瓶喝了算
Lucia: Then I'll drink it, I'll finish this bottle.
Lucia: 管子要插上吗
Lucia: Do I need to plug the pipe in?
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 不用谢
Lucia: No need to thank me.
Lucia: 唉呀妈sorry
Lucia: Oh my god, sorry.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Jake:诸事不顺
Jake: Everything's going wrong.
Lucia: 诸事不顺哈哈哈
Lucia: Everything's going wrong, hahaha.
Jake:昨天你好像也早上就咬到了嘴是吧
Jake: Yesterday, you also bit your lip in the morning, right?
Lucia: 哦对是靠
Lucia: Oh right, damn.
Jake:哦对是
Jake: Oh right.
Jake:应该多看看黄历
Jake: You should check the calendar more.
Jake:昨天可能确实是大灾大灾日
Jake: Yesterday was probably really an unlucky day.
Lucia: 靠
Lucia: Damn.
Lucia: 昨天是几号来着
Lucia: What date was it yesterday?
Lucia: 不是我的幸运数字
Lucia: Not my lucky number.
Jake:昨天19
Jake: Yesterday was the 19th.
Lucia: OK fine
Lucia: OK, fine.
Jake:这个好难转化呀
Jake: This is so hard to convert.
Lucia: 为什么长成这样
Lucia: Why does it look like this?
Jake:为什么长成这样
Jake: Why does it look like this?
Lucia: 你是一次性转化了两个吗没有
Lucia: Did you convert two at once? No.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Jake:还有一个还在台上呢
Jake: There's still one on the stage.
Lucia: 噢那就好
Lucia: Oh, that's good.
Lucia: 要不然的话
Lucia: Otherwise,
Lucia: 我就不知道你的这个成功率是多少了
Lucia: I wouldn't know what your success rate is.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 不过也没所谓
Lucia: But it doesn't really matter.
Jake:不过也没所谓
Jake: But it doesn't really matter.
Lucia: 他只是一个
Lucia: He's just a...
Jake:他只是一个
Jake: He's just a
Lucia: 小游戏
Lucia: Little game
Jake:一个重要指标
Jake: An important indicator
Lucia: 人类无聊的时候
Lucia: When humans are bored
Lucia: 就会干一些奇怪的事情
Lucia: They do strange things
Lucia: 哎呀你学会了吗
Lucia: Oh, have you learned it?
Alice:是你们学校的吗
Alice: Is it from your school?
Shure: 对没错
Shure: Yes, that's right
Alice:对你们学校
Alice: Your school
Alice:包子真有那么好吃
Alice: Are the buns really that good?
Shure: 不知道他能吃32个
Shure: I don't know, he can eat 32 of them
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 我也是是个那他
Shure: I think he just
Katrina: 他一个人吃32个
Katrina: He ate 32 by himself
Shure: 我不知道他为什么点32个
Shure: I don't know why he ordered 32
Lucia: 这个葡萄洗好了吗
Lucia: Are these grapes washed?
Lucia: 嗯因为谢谢大
Lucia: Hmm, because thank you
Alice:因为如果是食堂的包子话
Alice: Because if it's the cafeteria buns
Alice:应该有那个什么补助之类的
Alice: There should be some kind of subsidy
Shure: 反正就这么大的那种包子
Shure: Anyway, those buns are this big
Alice:什么馅啊
Alice: What filling?
Alice:有这么好吃
Alice: Are they that delicious?
Shure: 牛肉馅还行吧
Shure: Beef filling, it's okay
Shure: 我只能说我那天尝了一口
Shure: I can only say I tried a bite that day
Alice:你吃过吗
Alice: Have you had them?
Shure: 就是凤凰包子味
Shure: They taste like regular buns
Shure: 没有什么特别的感觉
Shure: Nothing special
Alice:你们最近是不是开了一个什么自创
Alice: Did you guys recently open a creative store or something?
Alice:那个什么自那个那个文创店
Alice: Some kind of cultural shop?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Alice:刷到了
Alice: I saw it
Shure: 哎
Shure: Oh
Shure: 那事都顶了热搜第二了天
Shure: The incident with Zheng Feng even hit second place on trending
Lucia: 什么
Lucia: What?
Alice:撤的也挺快
Alice: It was taken down quickly too
Alice:就是一个很很很很会
Alice: It was a very very very good
Alice:他们需要的啊
Alice: They needed it
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice:你们不知道吗
Alice: You guys don't know?
Lucia: 不知道我最近没怎么刷
Lucia: I don't know, I haven't been scrolling much lately.
Lucia: 这是什么知识
Lucia: What kind of knowledge is this?
Alice:文娱知识
Alice: Entertainment knowledge.
Alice:不对不是不是知识
Alice: No wait, it's not knowledge.
Alice:文娱八卦之类的
Alice: It's like entertainment gossip.
Lucia: 最近几天太忙了都没有刷这些软件
Lucia: I've been too busy these past few days, haven't been on those apps.
Shure: 不是上上周的事
Shure: Wasn't it from the week before last?
Shure: 就来之前的事应该是
Shure: Should be from just before we came.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I...
Alice:你之后要去哪读书啊
Alice: Where are you going to study next?
Katrina: 我去南京
Katrina: I'm going to Nanjing.
Katrina: 我去东南那边
Katrina: I'm heading to Southeast University.
Shure: 哎有书读啊真好
Shure: Oh, it's nice to have a place to study.
Lucia: 哦原来这是肥肠
Lucia: Oh, so this is pork intestine.
Lucia: 让我解锁一下一种新食物
Lucia: Let me unlock a new food.
Katrina: 拿碗分是吗
Shure: 拿碗分吧
Shure: Let's split it up.
Shure: 别一下又打了啊
Shure: Don't hit it again.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 这是谁谁的电脑
Shure: Whose computer is this?
Shure: 收一下吧
Shure: Put it away.
Jake:花洒花洒下
Jake: Move the showerhead.
Shure: 谁的
Shure: Whose is it?
Jake:雨啊花
Jake: The rain shower.
Shure: 啊他闪的电脑是吗
Shure: Oh, is it the flashing computer?
Shure: 昨天不会来打游戏来了吧哈哈哈
Shure: Did you come here to play games yesterday, haha?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:打完游戏抢红包贼开心
Jake: Played games and grabbed red envelopes, super happy.
Shure: 你在这打游戏来着是吗
Shure: You were playing games here?
Shure: 收下收下
Shure: Put it away.
Lucia: 123
Lucia: 这凳子估计还是不够
Lucia: This chair might not be enough.
Lucia: 嘟嘟嘟嘟
Lucia: Doot doot doot doot.
Lucia: 哎我今天早上拿上来一包好像
Lucia: Hey, I brought up a pack this morning, I think.
Jake:他这有貔貅吗
Jake: Does he have a pixiu?
Shure: 他这个是
Shure: This one is...
Lucia: 哎没有吗
Lucia: Oh, he doesn't?
Lucia: 那我再拿一把
Lucia: Then I'll grab another.
Jake:不是就是外外
Jake: No, it's just outside, outside
Shure: kitanweps
Lucia: 这上面有两包
Lucia: There are two packs on this
Lucia: 那就拿这个吧
Lucia: Then let's take this one
Lucia: 嗯啊头发怎么这么乱
Lucia: Huh, why is my hair so messy
Lucia: 你好呀
Lucia: Hello
Lucia: 我靠
Lucia: Oh my god
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 最多干了快一万
Shure: Did almost ten thousand at most
Shure: 最后一分钱没给
Shure: Didn't get a penny in the end
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:我们钱币即将发售
Jake: Our currency is about to be released
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Jake:我们货币即将发售
Jake: Our currency is about to be released
Shure: 我们的币
Shure: Our coin
Shure: 子上链了家人们
Shure: It's on the chain, folks
Jake:大家大家忘掉这件事情
Jake: Everyone, everyone forget about this
Jake:10年之后再想起来
Jake: Think about it again in 10 years
Shure: 然后就发现自己富了是吗
Shure: And then find out you're rich, right?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:财务自由职业自由
Jake: Financial freedom, career freedom
Shure: 真的会吗杨老板
Shure: Will that really happen, Jake?
Tasha: 往我的账户里面先充5050个
Tasha: First, load 5050 into my account
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Lucia: 呵
Lucia: Heh
Shure: 什么时候能让我实现财富自由呢
Shure: When will I achieve financial freedom?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake
Jake:那就得
Jake: That depends
Alice:快的话今晚就可以
Alice: If we're quick, maybe tonight
Jake:你
Jake: You
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么做的这个哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha how do you do this, hahaha
Lucia: 呵呵
Lucia: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia: 这已经开始画饼了是吗
Lucia: Is this the start of making promises?
Shure: 今天晚上你先选一个别的饼
Shure: Tonight, pick another promise
Tasha: 少个凳子
Tasha: Missing a chair
Tasha: 再来个凳子
Tasha: Get another chair
Tasha: 哦 还少一个櫈 子
Tasha: Oh, still missing a chair
Jake:好吃吗火烧
Jake: Is the roasted bun tasty?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:好吃
Jake: Tasty.
Lucia: 我来分发一下
Lucia: I'll distribute this.
Jake:驴肉对
Jake: Donkey meat, right.
Jake:这就是驴肉
Jake: This is donkey meat.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 要个这个就行了
Tasha: Just need this.
Tasha: 我不要筷子了
Tasha: I don't need chopsticks.
Lucia: 那那给给健康好了
Lucia: Then, let's give this to Health.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 那这筷子就放这
Lucia: I'll just leave the chopsticks here.
Jake:我我还有
Jake: I still have...
Jake:我还有一套餐具
Jake: I still have another set of utensils.
Lucia: 还有一套餐具啊
Lucia: Another set of utensils, huh?
Jake:是吗这是我的啊
Jake: Really? This is mine, right?
Tasha: 这这还有筷子呢
Tasha: There are chopsticks here, too.
Lucia: 啊刚不是给你了一套
Lucia: Didn't I just give you a set?
Jake:这是啊这不是我
Jake: This is... this isn't mine.
Lucia: 笑死了我刚刚还以为你有两个人
Lucia: I'm dying of laughter, I thought you had two sets.
Lucia: 我靠我有两个人哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my gosh, I thought I had two sets, hahaha.
Jake:我有两个人
Jake: I have two sets.
Shure: 卤煮火烧
Shure: Lu Zhuhuo Shao.
Jake:呃我也吃火烧
Jake: Uh, I'll have huo shao too.
Lucia: 呃我也是国宝
Lucia: Uh, I'm also a national treasure.
Jake:今晚吃什么
Jake: What's for dinner tonight?
Tasha: 今晚吃什么
Tasha: What's for dinner tonight?
Jake:麦麦当劳汉堡是吧
Jake: McDonald's burger, right?
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡嘿嘿
Tasha: McDonald's burger, hehe.
Lucia: 你们这边有了吗
Lucia: Do you guys have it here?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake:我们吃过麦当劳汉堡吗
Jake: Have we had McDonald's burgers before?
Tasha: 我们吃过麦当劳汉堡吗
Tasha: Have we had McDonald's burgers before?
Lucia: 你给我买了个汉堡
Lucia: You bought me a burger.
Tasha: 没有来肯德基
Tasha: No, we went to KFC.
Jake:还肯德基
Jake: And KFC.
Shure: 我先不要
Shure: I'll pass for now.
Jake:第一天肯德基是吧
Jake: First day at KFC, right?
Lucia: 哦那我吃了
Lucia: Oh, then I'll eat it.
Shure: 要加点蒜泥吗
Shure: Want to add some garlic paste?
Lucia: 有吗
Lucia: Do you have any?
Shure: 中文还来得及教吧
Shure: We can still teach Chinese, right?
Shure: 今天早上讲
Shure: We talked about it this morning.
Shure: 明天才解说
Shure: The explanation is tomorrow.
其他人 ：你就发一个标题
Others: Just put up a title.
Shure: 来是这里的
Shure: It's right here.
Shure: 帮忙拿一个蒜泥
Shure: Can you help me get some garlic paste?
Shure: 首先倒倒倒里了
Shure: First, pour it in.
Tasha: 啊我只是想要一个娃哈哈
Tasha: Ah, I just wanted a Wahaha.
Jake:那你娃哈那
Jake: Then go get your Wahaha.
Shure: 倒倒这边我给你开了一瓶
Shure: Pour it here. I opened a bottle for you.
Jake:那你待着吧
Jake: Then you stay here.
Jake:你待着
Jake: Stay here.
Tasha: 算了
Tasha: Forget it.
Lucia: 我给你开了一瓶娃哈哈
Lucia: I opened a bottle of Wahaha for you.
Shure: 你还没喝呢
Shure: You haven't drunk it yet.
Tasha: 还有谁要
Tasha: Anyone else want one?
Jake:是是是我想是的
Jake: Yes, yes, I think so.
Lucia: 你还没喝呢
Lucia: You haven't drunk it yet.
Shure: 这韭菜花先不用
Shure: We don't need the chive flower now.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 都行可以
Lucia: Anything is fine.
Alice:还有个俘虏
Alice: There's another captive.
其他人：这是他早期的食物
Others: This was his early food.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, hmm.
其他人：他早期的时候 不是已经
Others: In the early days, he wasn't already...
Alice:这个要吗
Alice: Do you want this?
Lucia: 放这好了
Lucia: Just put it here.
Lucia: 如果一会大家想加可以加
Lucia: If anyone wants to add it later, they can.
Tasha: 我的妈呀
Tasha: Oh my God.
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Lucia: 啊那要加香菜吗
Lucia: Oh, do you want to add cilantro?
Shure: 呃他啥不吃
Shure: Uh, what doesn't he eat?
Lucia: 呃他啥不吃
Lucia: Uh, what doesn't he eat?
Lucia: 他们那有有一碗
Lucia: They already have a bowl.
Lucia: 那就不加
Lucia: Then don't add it.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 这是啥呀
Lucia: What's this?
Lucia: 哦给等会
Lucia: Oh, wait a minute.
Lucia: 嗯谢谢
Lucia: Hmm, thank you.
其他人：我
Others: I...
其他人：ad钙是吗
Others: Is it AD calcium?
其他人：可以来一瓶
Others: Can I get a bottle?
其他人：有北冰洋吗
Others: Do you have Beibingyang?
Alice:楼下有
Alice: It's downstairs.
Shure: 我要要北冰洋
Shure: I want a Beibingyang.
Jake:这卤乳是不是得有勺啊
Jake: Does this marinade need a spoon?
Shure: 不用啊
Shure: No, it doesn't.
Jake:不用了
Jake: No need then.
Alice: ：那有勺哎
Alice: There’s a spoon though.
Jake:啊有勺
Jake: Ah, there's a spoon.
Jake:哦原来有勺可以
Jake: Oh, so there is a spoon. Okay.
Shure: 他火上好像都在底下
Shure: It seems like it's all at the bottom.
Tasha: 麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Tasha: 麦麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: Mc-Mc-McDonald's burger.
Jake:比什么
Jake: Compared to what?
Jake:比炸弹好吃
Jake: It's better than a bomb.
Jake:卤煮
Jake: Marinade.
Shure: 招信他的杨老板
Shure: Trust Jake with this.
Alice:有这些料要吗
Alice: Do you want these ingredients?
Shure: 他不专业
Shure: He's not professional.
Lucia: 啊 哦我有一个
Lucia: Ah, oh, I have one.
Shure: 我怎么插
Shure: How do I plug this in?
Shure: 插不进去啊
Shure: I can't plug it in.
Alice:蒜花然后
Alice: Garlic sprouts and then...
Alice:辣椒油
Alice: Chili oil.
Alice:应该还有个腐乳
Alice: There should be some fermented tofu.
Lucia: 这是什么痱子吗
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes, that's right.
Jake:你为什么不吃卤猪
Jake: Why aren't you eating the marinade?
Jake:好丑呀好丑
Jake: It's so ugly, so ugly.
Lucia: 我吃到血味了
Lucia: I tasted blood.
Jake:这丑吗
Jake: Is this ugly?
Tasha: 可他都是大肠小肠大脑小脑的感觉
Tasha: But it all feels like large intestines, small intestines, big brains, small brains.
其他人 ：感觉瞧不起谁呢
Others: Feels like you're looking down on someone.
其他人 ：谁也没有个东西哈哈哈
Others: No one has anything, hahaha.
Alice:那你为什么把别人吃下肚
Alice: Then why did you eat someone else?
Jake:它有3种是吧大肠肝
Jake: It has three types, right? Large intestines, liver...
Lucia: 肺吧这是
Lucia: Lungs, I think.
Jake:肺
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:面啊
Jake: Noodles.
Lucia: 我也想问
Lucia: I wanted to ask too.
Lucia: 火烧是哪个部位
Lucia: Which part is roasted?
Shure: 对这面块块就是火烧
Shure: Yeah, this piece of dough is roasted.
Tasha: 啊是什么
Tasha: What is it?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This.
Jake:面
Jake: Noodles.
Jake:就驴肉火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat roasted bun.
Jake:就是驴肉和火烧
Jake: It's just donkey meat and roasted bun.
Jake:就是驴肉火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat roasted bun.
Lucia: 是这样的吗
Lucia: Is it like this?
Jake:煎驴肉就是那个东西
Jake: Fried donkey meat is that thing.
Lucia: 尝一个
Lucia: I'll try one.
Jake:是吧你看
Jake: Right, look at this.
Shure: 面面面饼饼
Shure: Noodles, noodles, pancakes.
Tasha: 这个就是
Tasha: This is it.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:对用火烧出来的面
Jake: Yeah, made with roasted dough.
Lucia: 好神奇啊
Lucia: So amazing.
Lucia: 发出感叹
Lucia: Expressing amazement.
Jake:多半是没吃过牛肉火烧
Jake: Probably never had beef roasted buns.
Shure: 我有次吃河北人带来的卤火烧
Shure: Once I had braised roasted buns brought by someone from Hebei.
Shure: 真的是真他妈好吃
Shure: It was really freaking delicious.
Jake:怎么带过来的就
Jake: How did they bring it?
Shure: 怎么带过来的
Shure: How did they bring it?
Shure: 就他带过来
Shure: They just brought it.
Shure: 肉冷的都很好吃我去
Shure: Even the cold meat was delicious, damn.
Jake:这3个东西
Jake: These three things.
Jake:你们用了吗
Jake: Did you use them?
Shure: 用了把蒜汁和那个辣椒油浇了就行
Shure: Yeah, just pour the garlic sauce and chili oil, that's it.
Jake:用了
Jake: Used them.
Shure: 那个韭菜花一般不加
Shure: Usually don't add the chive flower sauce.
其他人 ：太专业了
Others: So professional.
Shure: low口
Shure: Low level.
其他人：从你妈妈肚子里再吃
Others: You started eating from your mom's womb.
Shure: 必须的
Shure: Absolutely.
Jake:这 啥呀腐乳
Jake: What's this, fermented tofu?
Alice:腐乳
Alice: Fermented tofu.
Jake:腐乳加吗
Jake: Do we add fermented tofu?
Shure: 腐竹不加
Shure: No fermented tofu.
Jake:不加好
Jake: No need to add it.
Shure: 也可以尝试
Shure: We can give it a try.
Lucia: 也可以尝试
Lucia: We can give it a try.
Shure: 但我没加过
Shure: But I've never added it before.
Lucia: 但我没夹过
Lucia: But I've never picked it up before.
Shure: 我不够local
Shure: I'm not local enough.
Jake:咱要不顺势把豆汁撒在床上
Jake: How about we just spill the soy milk on the bed?
Lucia: 我们买豆汁了吗
Lucia: Did we buy soy milk?
Tasha: 买了一瓶吧
Tasha: We bought a bottle, right?
Alice:不是买了一瓶吗
Alice: Didn't we buy a bottle?
Alice:在哪呢走来
Alice: Where is it? Bring it over.
Jake:走来
Jake: Bring it over.
Jake:先说要吃完吗
Jake: Should we finish eating first?
Jake:别的吃不了
Jake: Can't eat anything else.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不是吃饱了再喝
Lucia: Isn't it better to drink after eating?
Lucia: 那个不是危险性更大吗
Lucia: Isn't that even more dangerous?
Lucia: 哈哈哈说这么直白干什么
Lucia: Haha, why are you saying it so bluntly?
Tasha: 已经要吐了
Tasha: I'm already about to puke.
Shure: 我不吃
Shure: I'm not eating it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 我喝过
Shure: I've drunk it before.
Lucia: 我没吃过
Lucia: I've never eaten it.
Shure: 我怕吃完咱们又喝一杯了
Shure: I'm afraid after eating, we'll drink another cup.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 下午直接倒了
Shure: We'll collapse in the afternoon.
Alice:下午直接走那次在街头买了一一袋
Alice: That time in the afternoon, we bought a bag on the street.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 夹一个
Lucia: Pick one up.
Jake:接头一袋
Jake: A bag on the street.
Shure: 这个活必须我来干
Shure: I have to do this job.
Alice:我们同学3个人去买一一罐
Alice: Our classmates, three of us went to buy a can.
Shure: 我不能让私藏货币的事情给给别人做
Shure: I can't let someone else handle the hidden currency.
Tasha: 当时说是什么味来着
Tasha: What did they say it tasted like?
Tasha: 反正中午吃的全部都吐了
Tasha: Anyway, everything we ate at noon was thrown up.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 听起来好危险啊
Lucia: Sounds so dangerous.
其他人：这个
Others: This...
其他人：真的会在几十年后让我们财富自由吗
Others: Will this really make us financially free in a few decades?
Jake:这个怎么怎么炒啊
Jake: How do you trade this?
Shure: 你相你相信30年后财务自由
Shure: Do you believe you'll be financially free in 30 years?
Shure: 不相信你能活到30年
Shure: I don't believe you'll live to see 30 years.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 我应该差不多吧
Shure: I probably will.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Shure: 50岁我还活不到吗
Shure: Can't I live to 50?
Shure: 这么能活吗
Shure: Can I really live that long?
Shure: 那差不多
Shure: Well, probably.
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Probably.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Lucia: 而且还要考虑通货膨胀因素
Lucia: And we also have to consider inflation.
Shure: 金币很珍惜
Shure: Gold coins are precious.
Shure: 就是只有150个
Shure: There are only 150.
Shure: 到时候要是马斯克看看上了
Shure: If Elon Musk takes a look at it.
Shure: 然后马斯克在推上发一句话
Shure: And Elon Musk tweets about it.
Shure: 就必须能涨到马斯克16,000
Shure: It must go up to Musk's 16,000.
Tasha: 一钩币
Tasha: A coin hook.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 对如果有一天
Shure: Yeah, if one day...
Lucia: 那就在
Lucia: Then...
Lucia: 这个艰巨的任务就得交给杨老板了
Lucia: This tough task has to go to Jake.
Jake:真的会发生150个币吗
Jake: Will there really be 150 coins?
Tasha: 真的会发行150个虚拟币吗
Tasha: Will there really be 150 virtual coins?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 我跟你说
Shure: Let me tell you.
Shure: 有一天就是大一的时候
Shure: One day in freshman year...
Jake:是发150个币
Jake: They issued 150 coins.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 大一的时候张晨他晚上睡得很晚
Shure: In freshman year, Zhang Chen stayed up late.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 然后张晨在刷推特
Shure: And Zhang Chen was browsing Twitter.
Shure: 看见了马斯克说屎逼
Shure: He saw Musk say something nasty.
Shure: 你知道那个逼吗
Shure: You know that word?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 骂的张晨当时就刷到了
Shure: Zhang Chen saw it immediately.
Shure: 其实其实我没睡
Shure: Actually, I didn't sleep.
Shure: 但是他以为我睡
Shure: But he thought I was asleep
Shure: 他没跟我说那个时候在
Shure: He didn't tell me that at the time
Shure: 那个时候在地下都没那
Shure: At that time, underground
Shure: 个使劲都没上大交易所
Shure: Even with all the effort, it didn't get to the major exchange
Shure: 马上他直接下了个小小交易所
Shure: He immediately went to a small exchange
Shure: 赶快买了2,000的
Shure: Quickly bought 2,000 worth
Shure: 使劲交钱就变8,000
Shure: With more effort, it turned into 8,000
Lucia: 厉害
Lucia: Impressive
Shure: 走我赚钱
Shure: Let's go, I'm making money
Lucia: 修硕
Lucia and Shure
Tasha: 之前还是刚
Tasha: Before, I was just
Tasha: 才一直在苏州
Tasha: Always in Suzhou
Shure: 挖了个小1千
Shure: Dug up a small 1,000
Shure: 把我显卡挖机了
Shure: Used my graphics card to mine
Shure: 我去维修的时候
Shure: When I went to repair it
Shure: 然后问你这鞋上有两道黑伤
Shure: They asked why there were two black marks on my shoes
Jake:有用什么卡吗
Jake: Did you use any card?
Shure: 303060 哎
Shure: 3060, oh
Jake:就就我给你了哈哈
Jake: Yeah, I gave it to you haha
Shure: 不不不
Shure: No, no, no
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: 哥傻者哦
Shure: Bro, you're silly
Shure: 答应者净拿我笔记本
Shure: Agreed to take my laptop
其他人：  2060
Others: 2060
Shure: 哦 20602060
Shure: Oh, 2060, 2060
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no
Shure: 带笔记本没有
Shure: Didn't bring the laptop
Shure: 然后那个修电脑的人就很不可思议
Shure: Then the computer repair guy was really amazed
Shure: 就说我
Shure: He said I
Shure: 说我就是玩游戏打英雄联盟打多了
Shure: He said I played League of Legends too much
其他人 ：打英雄联盟打多了
Others: Played League of Legends too much
Shure: 其实是一天24小时挖方法的
Shure: Actually, I was mining 24 hours a day
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 你们宿舍电不会耗很快吗
Lucia: Didn't your dorm's electricity run out quickly?
Shure: 对那两个月就是我跟张德晨付电费
Shure: Yeah, for those two months, Zhang Dechen and I paid the electricity bill
Shure: 因为那段时间的那段时间地太值钱了
Shure: Because during that time, it was really valuable
Shure: 电费已经完全耗了
Shure: The electricity bill was completely consumed
Shure: 就大概是三三月份挖了吧
Shure: It was around March when we started mining
Shure: 五月份国家就出台这个政策
Shure: In May, the country introduced this policy 政治问题
Shure: 然后就腰斩
Shure: And then it got cut in half
Shure: 对不起对不起
Shure: I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Shure: 我知道虚拟货币机器不稳定性
Shure: I know virtual currency machines are unstable.
Shure: 国家就应该支持
Shure: The country should support it.
Shure: 确实哈哈
Shure: Indeed, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 这都是泡沫经济
Shure: It's all a bubble economy.
Shure: 挤一下挤一下炒鸡
Shure: Squeeze it, squeeze it, stir-fry.
Jake:12:21场景
Jake: 12:21 scene.
Shure: 然后标签打上危险人物
Shure: Then label it as a dangerous person.
Jake:就是网管
Jake: It's just the network manager.
Jake:基本上就干这个
Jake: Basically, just doing that.
Jake:就是计个时间
Jake: Just keeping time.
Jake:哈哈哈要举报
Jake: Hahaha, need to report.
Shure: 不知道你们记不记得那个天津那个人
Shure: Do you remember that guy from Tianjin?
Shure: 也没酒驾
Shure: He wasn't drunk driving.
Shure: 就喜欢撞人那种事
Shure: He just liked to hit people with his car.
Shure: 搭桥上撞人
Shure: Hit people on the bridge.
Lucia: 感觉确实超逼超逗的
Lucia: It really feels super intense and funny.
Lucia: 决定到这边来夹一个
Lucia: Decided to come here and grab one.
Lucia: 还挺好吃的
Lucia: It's pretty tasty.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 第一次吃吧
Shure: First time eating it?
Lucia: 对没吃过
Lucia: Yeah, never had it before.
Shure: 你以前你以前吃肥肠吗
Shure: Did you used to eat pork intestines?
Lucia: 嗯肥肠我吃过
Lucia: Hmm, I've had pork intestines before.
Lucia: 跟就就是放在面里当浇头的那种
Lucia: Like in noodles as a topping.
Alice:那你可能也会吃炒肝
Alice: Then you might also eat stir-fried liver.
Alice:你说北京的那种炒肝吗嗯
Alice: You mean the Beijing style stir-fried liver?
Lucia: 啊我不喜欢那个特别咸我觉得
Lucia: Ah, I don't like that one, it's too salty, I think.
Alice:你不喜欢
Alice: You don't like it?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:那咸
Alice: It's salty.
Lucia: 是不是我去的地方不对啊
Lucia: Maybe I went to the wrong place?
Lucia: 我觉得特别咸
Lucia: I think it's super salty.
Alice:可能是炒干
Alice: Could be the stir-fried liver.
Alice:还没这个咸呢
Alice: Not as salty as this though.
Alice:就比这个会淡一点点
Alice: Just a bit lighter than this.
Lucia: 下次再试试
Lucia: Try it next time.
Alice:感觉超哥糊嘴
Alice: Feels like his mouth is all sticky.
Lucia: 对他那种黏糊糊的是吧
Lucia: Yeah, that sticky, gooey stuff, right?
Lucia: 像放了布丁粉一样的感觉
Lucia: Like there's pudding powder in it.
Alice:感觉是藕粉的那种清晰
Alice: Feels like the clarity of lotus root powder.
Lucia: 嗯对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Alice:黏糊吧唧
Alice: Sticky and gooey.
Jake:是什么呀辣椒
Jake: What is it, chili?
Alice:辣椒油
Alice: Chili oil.
Alice:韭花酱
Alice: Chive flower sauce.
Jake:那我多蘸多加点汤是吧
Jake: So I dip more and add more soup, right?
Alice:你直接倒吧
Alice: Just pour it in directly.
Tasha: 你截到没截到
Tasha: Did you capture it or not?
Shure: 十八八的
Shure: Eighteen eighty-eight.
Alice:我想吃那个
Alice: I want to eat that.
Lucia: 胳膊疼哈哈
Lucia: My arm hurts, haha.
Tasha: 多米诺骨牌
Tasha: Dominoes.
Jake:你这吸管咬得可以
Jake: You've really bitten this straw.
Jake:他这吸管
Jake: His straw...
Tasha: 没有跟我一样
Tasha: Not like mine.
Jake:好像没有
Jake: Doesn't seem like it.
Lucia: 我一般都是喝完了才有
Lucia: I usually do it after I finish drinking.
Jake:咬的很有艺术感
Jake: You've bitten it artistically.
Tasha: 这是一种领地意识
Tasha: It's a kind of territorial instinct.
Tasha: 导致没有第二个人
Tasha: So no one else...
Tasha: 想喝我的饮料哈哈哈
Tasha: Wants to drink my beverage, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你会喝羊杂汤吗
Lucia: Do you drink lamb offal soup?
Alice:你会喝羊杂汤吗
Alice: Do you drink lamb offal soup?
Lucia: 我喝过喜欢吗
Lucia: I've had it, do you like it?
Alice:喜欢吗取决于他做的好不好
Alice: It depends on how well it's made.
Lucia: 取决于他做的好不好
Lucia: It depends on how well it's made.
Jake:喝什么哦
Jake: What are you drinking?
Tasha: 羊杂汤
Tasha: Lamb offal soup.
Alice:羊杂汤
Alice: Lamb offal soup.
Lucia: 羊杂汤我感觉有的做的还确实还行
Lucia: Some of it is actually pretty good.
Lucia: 有的做的不好吃有点腥
Lucia: Some are not good, a bit gamey.
Jake:泡馍用的吗
Jake: Is it used for soaked bread?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 其实像这里面这个肺我就不是特喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I don't really like the lung here.
Lucia: 因为我刚吃了一块饭他有血块味
Lucia: Because I just had a piece, and it tasted like blood clots.
Lucia: 我就没再吃了
Lucia: So I didn't eat any more.
Lucia: 但是其他的都很好吃
Lucia: But everything else is really delicious.
Alice:心好吃啊
Lucia: 对心好吃
Lucia: 心没有味道
Lucia: It's not overpowering.
Alice:  比较韧
Alice: It's quite chewy.
Lucia: 而且很有嚼劲
Lucia: And it's very chewy.
Jake:咱这豆汁什么时候喝呀
Jake: When are we drinking the soy milk?
Jake:明天后天谁买的
Jake: Who bought it for tomorrow or the day after?
Jake:哈哈哈这是你吗
Jake: Haha, was it you?
Shure: 谁买谁喝啊
Shure: Whoever bought it should drink it.
Alice:谁买谁可以指定喝
Alice: Whoever bought it can choose who drinks it.
Tasha: 谁买的
Tasha: Who bought it?
Lucia: 谁买谁指定喝可还行
Lucia: The one who bought it can choose who drinks it, huh?
Jake:这个可以
Jake: That works.
Jake:你开了吗
Jake: Did you open it?
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: All right.
Lucia: 超市里这种豆汁
Lucia: The soy milk in the supermarket,
Lucia: 会不会做一些口味上的改良啊
Lucia: do you think they improve the flavor?
Lucia: 要不然话不就没人买吗
Lucia: Otherwise, no one would buy it, right?
Tasha: 对啊肯定是这样子
Tasha: Yeah, definitely.
Lucia: 啊头好疼
Lucia: Ah, my head hurts.
Lucia:  酷狗
Lucia: Cool dog.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:thank you
Alice: Thank you.
Lucia: hello 酷狗
Lucia: Hello, cool dog.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 什么东西火烧
Lucia: What's this thing, roasted bun?
Alice:火烧
Alice: Roasted bun.
Alice:嗯不宣
Alice: Hmm, not fluffy.
Tasha: 我发现北方的馒头都不腥
Tasha: I noticed the steamed buns in the North aren't fishy.
Tasha: 就是特别硬的那种
Tasha: They're just really hard.
Alice:我们家做馒头老用死面
Alice: My family makes steamed buns with dead dough.
Alice:我就不爱吃馒头
Alice: I don't like steamed buns.
Tasha: 那我爱吃活面馒头
Tasha: I prefer steamed buns made with active dough.
Alice:其实也不是死的
Alice: Actually, it's not completely dead.
Alice:有发酵但是比较邦邦硬比较湿
Alice: It's fermented, but it's quite hard and a bit wet.
Jake:哎这怎么开
Jake: Hey, how do you open this?
Jake:这是要干啥
Jake: What is this for?
Shure: 不是我拍的
Shure: I didn't film this.
Jake:遥控器在哪
Jake: Where's the remote?
Lucia: 我记得还有一个鹅是
Lucia: I remember there was a goose.
Lucia: 怎么弄的来着
Lucia: How did we do it again?
Lucia: 哈哈是不是很好玩
Lucia: Haha, isn't it fun?
Lucia: 还有这这个
Lucia: And there's this one.
Lucia: AI你学会了吗
Lucia: AI, did you learn it?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha
Jake:哎这个像鸽子
Jake: Hey, this looks like a pigeon.
Katrina: 哎快断气了
Katrina: Hey, it's almost out of breath.
Lucia: 微微这个是大雁吗
Lucia: Tasha, is this a swan?
Jake:这是两只手
Jake: These are two hands.
Jake:哈哈哈这啥呀这是你
Jake: Hahaha, what is this? Is this you?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈你好AI  啊
Lucia: Hahahaha, you're so AI.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Alice:蛇怎么弄啊
Alice: How do you do the snake?
Lucia: 蛇不会哎
Lucia: I can't do the snake.
Lucia: 有点像你说那种会吐吐吐那个什么呢
Lucia: It kind of looks like the one that spits something.
Jake:鸵鸟
Jake: Ostrich.
Jake:孔雀
Jake: Peacock.
Lucia: 嘿嘿
Lucia: Hehe
Tasha: 这像不像鹿
Tasha: Does this look like a deer?
Lucia: 哎象的象的
Lucia: Yeah, it does.
Jake:鸡冠头
Jake: Rooster head.
Lucia: 为什么大家同一个手势
Lucia: Why does everyone have the same gesture?
Lucia: 你就是鹿而我是孔雀
Lucia: You're a deer and I'm a peacock.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Lucia: 我记得我以前还会弄哎眼珠会动哎
Lucia: I remember I used to make the eyes move.
Alice:嘿眼珠会动
Alice: Hey, the eyes move.
Lucia: 好看
Lucia: Nice.
Lucia: 还有
Lucia: And
Jake:这
Jake: This
Lucia: 这是猫
Lucia: This is a cat.
Lucia: 什么石头
Lucia: What kind of stone?
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 猫
Lucia: Cat.
Alice:正在思考人类为什么要
Alice: Thinking about why humans are
Jake:一个山
Jake: A mountain
Jake:山洞
Jake: Cave
Jake:最左边
Jake: The far left
Lucia: 不会了小时候会好多
Lucia: I used to know a lot when I was a kid
Lucia: 我现在就只记得这个和这个狗
Lucia: Now I only remember this and this dog
Lucia: 汪汪汪
Lucia: Woof woof woof
Alice: ：会咬人吗
Alice: Does it bite?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: enough
Lucia: Enough
Lucia: 给大家表演一个天狗吃月亮月亮呢
Lucia: I'll perform a celestial dog eating the moon, the moon
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Lucia: 这是啥
Lucia: What is this?
Lucia: 哈哈好像好像驴
Lucia: Haha, it looks like a donkey
Jake:哈哈这个
Jake: Haha, this
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈这是什么
Tasha: Haha, what is this?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:螃蟹这是
Jake: It's a crab
Jake:这是螃蟹这是螃蟹
Jake: It's a crab, it's a crab
Lucia: 哎有点像
Lucia: Hey, it does look like one
Lucia: 再多两条腿就
Lucia: Just needs two more legs
Tasha: 这是龙吗
Tasha: Is this a dragon?
Jake:给你加俩
Jake: I'll add two more
Tasha: 狗
Tasha: Dog
Tasha: 这是东邪西毒的狗吗
Tasha: Is this the dog from "The East is Red"?
Tasha: 啊蝴蝶
Tasha: Ah, butterfly
Lucia: 啊原来如此
Lucia: Ah, I see
Lucia: 哪个
Lucia: Which one?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Lucia: 这是不是要那个傻掉
Lucia: Is this going to be silly?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 国际友好手势
Lucia: International friendly gesture
Lucia: 这是兔子
Lucia: It's a rabbit
Tasha: 这是美羊羊
Tasha: It's Pleasant Goat
Lucia: 这是美羊羊
Lucia: It's Pleasant Goat
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Jake:美羊羊美羊羊
Jake: Pretty Sheep, Pretty Sheep
Lucia: 我真是美羊羊
Lucia: I really am Pretty Sheep
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈可还行
Lucia: Haha, not bad
Lucia: 好饱哦
Lucia: I’m so full
Jake:连你的怎么也没有
Jake: Why don’t you have yours either?
Jake:看看你的是不是
Jake: Check if it's yours
Lucia: 内存满了
Lucia: Memory is full
Jake:看一看你是不是没有开
Jake: Check if you didn't turn it on
Jake:还是你每次要摁一下
Jake: Or do you have to press it every time?
Jake:它得亮着它才
Jake: It has to be on
Jake:你看一看
Jake: Take a look
Lucia: 您这个条他都没变化的
Lucia: This bar hasn't changed at all
Jake:那就电多
Jake: That means it has a lot of power
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay
Jake:可以看一下手机是不是在前进
Jake: Check if the phone is progressing
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:啊不是
Jake: Ah, no
Jake:就是手机上
Jake: Just on the phone
Lucia: OK IC就是手机上看这个电视电
Lucia: OK, IC, just check on the phone
Jake:对对对对是的
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, exactly
Jake:他电怎么样还
Jake: How is the power?
Lucia: OK
Jake:没连上
Jake: Not connected
Lucia: 那他怎么
Lucia: What’s going on
Jake:关了再开
Jake: Turn it off and on again
Lucia: 我手机快没存储空间了
Lucia: My phone is running out of storage space
Jake:清掉
Jake: Clear it
Lucia: 不行我存了好多素材不能抢
Lucia: No, I saved a lot of materials, can't delete
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:导出来
Jake: Export it
Lucia: 啊他确实在charging 98%
Lucia: Ah, it is indeed charging, 98%
Lucia: 早上怎么还好像还是100%呀
Lucia: Why was it still 100% in the morning?
Lucia: 他是不是冲的没有他耗的快呀
Lucia: Is it charging slower than it’s consuming?
Jake:嗯没关系没关系
Jake: Hmm, it's okay, it's okay
Lucia: 嗯没关系OK
Lucia: Hmm, it’s okay, okay
Lucia: never mind
Jake:一个小时下减20%可以接受了哈哈哈
Jake: A 20% decrease in an hour is acceptable, hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈OK
Lucia: Hahahaha OK
Lucia: 那么有人喝豆汁吗
Lucia: So, does anyone drink fermented mung bean juice?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Jake:可以晚一些
Jake: Maybe later
Lucia: 你喝过吗
Lucia: Have you tried it?
Jake:我喝过
Jake: Yes, I have
Lucia: 我喝过你喝过啊
Lucia: I have, you have?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 可是你看起来好像他并没有任
Lucia: But you don't seem to have any psychological shadow from it
Lucia: 何心理阴影的样子
Lucia: At all
Shure: 喂喂爹
Shure: Hey hey, Dad
Jake:呃就大不了吐了吧
Jake: Uh, at worst, I just throw up, right?
Shure: 你说那个
Shure: You mean that?
Jake:哈哈哈多大事吧哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, it's no big deal, hahaha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈不是
Lucia: Haha, no
Shure: 帮我把电脑开一下呗
Shure: Can you help me turn on the computer?
Lucia: 情绪怎么这么稳定啊哈哈
Lucia: Why are you so calm? Haha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 刚刚不是开过了吗
Shure: Didn't you already turn it on?
Shure: 但是你没有解锁
Shure: But you didn't unlock it
Lucia: 情绪怎么这么稳定啊
Lucia: Why are you so calm?
Shure: 你不是要远程吗
Shure: Don't you want to use it remotely?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 我就没没给你关
Shure: I didn't turn it off for you
Katrina: 卡皮巴拉转世
Katrina: Capybara reincarnation
Shure: 你得解锁完才能
Shure: You need to unlock it first
Jake:吐一下怎么了哈哈哈
Jake: What's wrong with throwing up? Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈你说到卡皮巴拉
Lucia: Haha, speaking of capybaras
Lucia: 我这里有一个特别可爱的表情包
Lucia: I have a really cute sticker of one
Jake:我我要学
Jake: I want to learn
Jake:一下这到底是个什么玩意
Jake: What is this thing exactly?
Alice:  ：卡皮巴拉
Alice: Capybara
Lucia: 哦我给你看
Lucia: Oh, let me show you
Lucia: 我发给你我发给你
Lucia: I'll send it to you, I'll send it to you
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know
Alice:  ：水豚
Alice: Capybara
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 你在哪呢
Lucia: Where are you?
Jake:我真不知道
Jake: I really don't know.
Shure: 然后帮我把那个向日葵拆开
Shure: Then help me take apart that sunflower.
Jake:在这在这在这在这
Jake: Here, here, here, here.
Lucia: 找不着你了
Lucia: I can't find you.
Lucia: 不是我给我给你看那个表情包
Lucia: No, I want to show you this meme.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 在这找到你好了
Lucia: I found you here.
Lucia: 就是丢了6分钟
Lucia: It's just been six minutes.
Lucia: 这个是这个是这这个吧
Lucia: This is, this is it, right?
Alice: ：对对对水豚
Alice: Yeah, yeah, a capybara.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 我从我朋友那里捞来的一个表情包
Lucia: I got this meme from a friend.
Lucia: 就特别可爱
Lucia: It's super cute.
Lucia: 下午好有什么倒忙是我能帮的吗
Lucia: Good afternoon, is there anything I can help with?
Jake:有什么倒忙是需要我能帮的吗
Jake: Is there anything you need help with?
Shure: 屁游戏我看一眼啊
Shure: Let me check the game.
Lucia: 就这个动物他情绪特别稳定
Lucia: This animal is very stable emotionally.
Jake:这个是它
Jake: This is it.
Jake:为什么叫
Jake: Why is it called...
Lucia: 他很可爱
Lucia: It's so cute.
Jake:它的学名就叫这个名字
Jake: Its scientific name is this.
Lucia: 他的学名就叫这个名字
Lucia: Its scientific name is this.
Lucia: 他学名就叫卡皮巴拉吧好像
Lucia: Its scientific name is Capybara, I think.
Jake:它叫水豚
Jake: It's called capybara.
Jake:水豚那为什么叫巴拉
Jake: Then why is it called 'bara'?
Lucia: 他为什么叫巴拉
Lucia: Why is it called 'bara'?
Jake:巴拉是什么
Jake: What's 'bara'?
Lucia: 巴拉是什么
Lucia: What's 'bara'?
Lucia: 英语翻译过来好像
Lucia: Translated to English, it's like...
Lucia: 为什么老跟他视频
Lucia: Why always video call with him?
Lucia: 就是谁卡皮瓜拉
Lucia: It's Capybara.
Lucia: 哦他好像他英语就叫卡皮巴拉
Lucia: Oh, I think its English name is Capybara.
Lucia: 还是怎么回事
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia: 是吗是的
Lucia: Is it? Yes.
Lucia: 好像是他
Lucia: I think so.
Katrina: 反正有个BGM总是这样配的
Katrina: Anyway, there's always a BGM like that.
Lucia: 哦他是在水里的吗
Lucia: Oh, is it in the water?
Jake:它为什么是水豚
Jake: Why is it called water pig?
Jake:它是在水里的吗
Jake: Is it in the water?
Katrina: 是这样会
Katrina: Yes, it's like this.
Jake:是的是它怎么
Jake: Yes, it's him, how...
Lucia: 是的是他
Lucia: Yes, it's him.
Lucia: 超可爱我觉得好像小马
Lucia: Super cute, I think it looks like a little horse.
Jake:嗯好像小马小驴刚吃过
Jake: Yeah, like a little horse or donkey that just ate.
Lucia: 这个可以吃吗
Lucia: Can we eat this?
Lucia: 应该不可以吃
Lucia: Probably not.
Lucia: 这种那个
Lucia: This type of...
Lucia: 那个字念什么
Lucia: How do you read this character?
Lucia: 啮齿还是什么类啮
Lucia: Rodents or something like that?
Lucia: 对那个动物那那一类的都不可以吃吧
Lucia: Yeah, animals from that category can't be eaten, right?
Katrina: 一般特别低的时候是开开不了的吗
Katrina: Usually when it's really low, it can't turn on, right?
Katrina: 但是他在充电
Katrina: But it's charging.
Jake:没有他就是他得一直亮着他才充电
Jake: No, it has to stay on to charge.
Jake:你现在才还是100%
Jake: It's still at 100%.
Lucia: 如果很低的话
Lucia: If it's really low...
Jake:显然是没有充的
Lucia: 如果很低的话他现在开不了
Lucia: If it's really low, it won't turn on now.
Lucia: 他得充一会才能再开
Lucia: It needs to charge a bit before it can turn on.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:就是你虽然是插上了但是他没有充
Jake: Even if you plug it in, it's not charging.
Jake:他没有开机充电
Jake: It doesn't charge when it's off.
Jake:网没有开
Jake: The network isn't on.
Jake:就他一点电都没有耗嘛对吧
Jake: It hasn't used any power, right?
Katrina: 你怎么什么梗都能接住
Katrina: How can you catch all the jokes?
Lucia: 10级冲浪大师
Lucia: Level 10 surfing master.
Katrina: 一天24小时28小时上网
Katrina: Online 28 hours a day.
Lucia: 上网28小时
Lucia: Online 28 hours.
Lucia: 上网
Lucia: Online.
Lucia: 我们这里的AI好多呀
Lucia: We have so many AIs here.
Lucia: 全天候在线
Lucia: Always online.
Jake:只是插根网线
Jake: Just plug in a network cable.
Jake:就我们插的是电线他插的是网线
Jake: We plug in power, they plug in the network.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 跟我的云服务器已经同步了
Shure: Already synced with my cloud server.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 不我不是AI
Lucia: No, I'm not an AI.
Lucia: 我只是一只树懒
Lucia: I'm just a sloth.
Jake:你是什么环境
Jake: What's your environment?
Shure: 我是
Shure: I'm...
Lucia: 你是什么环境
Lucia: What's your environment like?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 怎么了谢宾主
Shure: What's up, Xie Binzhu?
Jake:他他在哪啊
Jake: Where is he?
Katrina: 没叫你啊
Katrina: He didn't call you.
Shure: 他不是肖秀硕吗
Shure: Isn't he Xiao Xiuxuo?
Lucia: 他你可你可能收到了他的无线讯号
Lucia: Maybe you picked up his wireless signal.
Katrina: 他在下面真的叫啊
Katrina: He's really calling from below.
Katrina: 没听见他喊啊
Katrina: Didn't you hear him shout?
Lucia: 真的叫我也没听见
Lucia: I didn't hear him either.
Katrina: 你俩心灵感应啊
Katrina: You two have telepathy?
Jake:你们是哪个频段频段的
Jake: What frequency are you guys on?
Lucia: 你们是哪个频段的
Lucia: What frequency are you guys on?
Jake:多少赫兹
Jake: How many hertz?
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 我要搜啥来着啊腾讯云
Shure: What was I supposed to search for? Oh, Tencent Cloud.
Lucia: 打坐我还缺什么要买的呢
Lucia: What else do I need to buy for meditation?
Jake:我们还缺什么要买的吗
Jake: Do we need to buy anything else?
Jake:下午采购去
Jake: Let's go shopping this afternoon.
Jake:有必要吗
Jake: Is it necessary?
Shure: 可以远程盒马的这次
Shure: We can just use Hema remotely this time.
Lucia: 河马送货上门啊
Lucia: Hema delivers to your door, right?
Jake:咱要不换一家总盒马的
Jake: How about we switch from Hema?
Shure: 对主要盒马
Shure: Yeah, mainly Hema.
Lucia: 我是买吃的
Lucia: I'm buying food.
Katrina: 算是国内
Katrina: It's considered domestic.
Shure: 算是国内唯一一个这么好用的商超
Shure: It's considered the only really good supermarket in the country.
Katrina: 现在盒马品控下降
Katrina: Hema's quality control is declining.
Katrina: 不知是不是要被收购了
Katrina: Don't know if it's going to be acquired.
Lucia: 盒马不是一直是那个谁阿里那边的吗
Lucia: Hasn't Hema always been under Alibaba?
Katrina: 最近好像说听说可能要被收购啊
Katrina: Recently, I heard it might be acquired.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:阿里日本不好过呀
Jake: Alibaba isn't doing well in Japan.
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Lucia: 今年淘宝
Lucia: This year, Taobao...
Lucia: 今年年初的时候开始
Lucia: Since the beginning of the year...
Lucia: 淘宝也一直在搞新的市场市场攻略
Lucia: Taobao has also been exploring new market strategies.
Shure: 为什么我这个c键就输不进去呢我操
Shure: Why can't I type the 'C' key? Damn it.
Lucia: 我们除了奶油还要买什么来着
Lucia: Besides cream, what else do we need to buy?
Jake:得问问他都
Jake: Better ask him.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈显腿细
Shure: Hahaha, makes your legs look slimmer.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:买啥呀买啥呀
Jake: What are you buying? What are you buying?
Lucia: 咱冰箱里还有两块牛排呢
Lucia: We still have two steaks in the fridge.
Katrina: 套着好帅
Katrina: Looks so cool on you.
Katrina: 我要练老皮
Katrina: I want to practice Old Pi.
Katrina: 你看这这像55岁的吗
Katrina: Do I look like I'm 55?
Shure: 感觉我55岁差不多这个样子
Shure: I feel like I'll look like this when I'm 55.
Shure: 迷倒一片老太太
Shure: I'll charm all the old ladies.
Katrina: 55岁在抱着那吉他上人民公园
Katrina: At 55, holding that guitar, going to People's Park.
Katrina: 去唱摇滚去
Katrina: Going to sing rock songs.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:靠那5个一个币
Jake: Only 5 for one coin.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Jake:活下活下半身
Jake: Survive with half a body.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Katrina: 以后相亲
Katrina: In the future, for blind dates,
Jake:活下半生
Katrina: 简历上面写本人有5个一狗币
Katrina: I'll write on my resume that I have 5 dog coins.
Shure: 这边开着两个远程桌面
Shure: Running two remote desktops here.
Jake:BGM吗这是
Jake: Is this the BGM?
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Alice:北京野生动物园
Alice: Beijing Wildlife Park.
Alice:不是有那个咖啡吧啦吗
Alice: Isn't there that coffee bar?
Alice:好多人去跟他合影
Alice: Lots of people go take pictures with it.
Alice:就拿个水果啊啥顶在他的头上
Alice: They put fruits or something on its head.
Alice:反而他也不动
Alice: And it doesn't move.
Alice:就是活也可以不死
Alice: It can live without dying.
Lucia: 不死不活也行
Lucia: It can neither live nor die.
Alice:不活也行
Alice: It doesn't need to live.
Alice:哈哈哈活着也行死了也行
Alice: Hahaha, it can live or die, whatever.
Alice:随便你就你这种精神状态
Alice: Whatever, with that kind of spirit.
Lucia: 另先人类100年
Lucia: Leading humanity by 100 years.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:放个榴莲在头上
Jake: Put a durian on its head.
Alice:哈哈顶橘子就橘子上面再放橘子
Alice: Haha, put an orange, and then put another orange on top.
Shure: 榴莲好像他顶着有点费劲
Shure: A durian would be a bit too much.
Alice:就像顶杂技一样
Alice: Like a balancing act.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice:就不不动不管
Alice: Just ignore it, don't care.
Alice:淡淡的死亡感
Alice: A faint sense of death.
Alice:活着也行不活也行随便你
Alice: Living is fine, not living is fine, whatever.
Alice:下午什么安排
Alice: What's the plan for the afternoon?
Alice:买东西
Alice: Shopping.
Alice:估计快递也快到
Alice: I think the delivery should be arriving soon.
Jake:拆快递
Jake: Unbox the delivery.
Jake:你们拆快递
Jake: You guys unbox the delivery.
Lucia: 然后布置
Lucia: And then decorate.
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys...
Lucia: 然后收拾
Lucia: And then clean up.
Alice:该布置了
Alice: It's time to decorate.
Jake:布置那个问答
Jake: Decorate for the Q&A.
Alice:还要收拾
Alice: We still need to clean up.
Jake:问答的话GPT得干活啊
Jake: For the Q&A, GPT has to do the work.
Lucia: GPT出完我们来检查一下吧
Lucia: Once GPT is done, we'll check it.
Lucia: 要不然他胡说八道
Lucia: Otherwise, it might talk nonsense.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:每天都让他有一个胡说八道的机会
Jake: We give it one chance to talk nonsense every day.
Lucia: 每天都在
Lucia: Every day, it's...
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, that's it.
Alice:还是不知道为什么
Alice: Still don't know why.
Alice:那个什么一多少来着
Alice: What's that number again?
Jake:132132 是回文数
Jake: 132132, it's a palindrome.
Lucia: 132为什么是回纹数
Lucia: Why is 132 a palindrome?
Alice:还有那个为什么代表3月21
Alice: And why does it represent March 21?
Jake:也没整明白
Jake: Still don't get it.
Alice:为什么能用16多少来着代表
Alice: Why can it be represented by 16 something?
Jake:对这真是太离谱了这个
Jake: Yeah, that's really absurd.
Lucia: 一六几来着
Lucia: What was it, 16 what?
Alice:161 还是161吧
Alice: 161, or was it 161?
Lucia: 好像是为什么呢
Lucia: Seems like, why though?
Alice:为什么呢
Alice: Why though?
Jake:是这么说的
Jake: That's what he said.
Jake:他是说
Jake: He said...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm...
Jake:他是这么说的
Jake: That's what he said.
Jake:161 这个数字代表国际植树节3月21号
Jake: 161 represents International Arbor Day, March 21.
Jake:尽管他与世界第九日不是同一天哈
Jake: Even though it's not the same day as the World Day.
Alice:哈哈哈那我是不是还能代表328
Alice: Haha, then can I represent March 28 too?
Alice:尽管他们不是同一个数字哈哈哈
Alice: Even though they're not the same number, haha.
Jake:哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yes.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:是这么回事哈哈哈
Jake: That's how it is, haha.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 他哪怕把那个3月21除以2我都能接受
Lucia: Even if he divided March 21 by 2, I could accept that.
Lucia: 他给了一个什么奇怪的东西
Lucia: He gave some weird thing.
Jake:139 这个数字
Jake: 139, this number.
Jake:象征着地球大气中主要气体的数量
Jake: It symbolizes the number of main gases in Earth's atmosphere.
Lucia: 是139种吗
Lucia: Are there 139 types?
Jake:我觉得不是
Jake: I don't think so.
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea.
Lucia: 不是一共就那么几种吗
Lucia: Aren't there just a few types?
Lucia: 氢(H)、氦(He)、锂(Li)、铍(Be)、硼(B)、碳(C)、氮(N)、氧(O)、氟(F)、氖(Ne)、钠(Na)、镁(Mg)、铝(Al)、硅(Si)、硫(S)、
Lucia: Hydrogen (H), Helium (He), Lithium (Li), Beryllium (Be), Boron (B), Carbon (C), Nitrogen (N), Oxygen (O), Fluorine (F), Neon (Ne), Sodium (Na), Magnesium (Mg), Aluminum (Al), Silicon (Si), Sulfur (S),
Jake:他应该是组
Jake: He probably means groups.
Alice:他说气体数量
Alice: He said the number of gases.
Jake:组了一个什么CO2
Jake: Grouped something like CO2.
Jake:是吧对
Jake: Right?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:192
Jake: 192.
Jake:这个数字
Jake: This number.
Jake:可以象征全世界
Jake: Can symbolize the whole world.
Jake:大概有192个国家
Jake: There are about 192 countries.
Alice:元素
Alice: Elements.
Jake:需要参加世界第九日的活动
Jake: That need to participate in the Ninth World Day event.
Jake:这是是吗
Jake: Is that right?
Lucia: 只有192个国家吗
Lucia: Only 192 countries?
Alice:一共
Alice: In total.
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Jake:得200多吧我感觉
Jake: I think there are over 200.
Lucia: 好像吧
Lucia: Seems like it.
Alice:有的没资格参加吗
Alice: Some are not qualified to participate?
Alice:这意思吗
Alice: Is that what you mean?
Lucia: 没加入联合国吗
Lucia: Not part of the UN?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈不知道啊
Lucia: Hahaha, I don't know.
Jake:啊是吧
Jake: Ah, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈咱也不知道啊
Lucia: Hahaha, we don't know either.
Jake:108 在许多文化中
Jake: 108, in many cultures.
Jake:108是个神圣的数字
Jake: 108 is a sacred number.
Jake:象征着宇宙的和谐和完整
Jake: It symbolizes the harmony and completeness of the universe.
Lucia: 啊真的吗
Lucia: Oh, really?
Jake:也也代表着
Jake: It also represents...
Lucia: 我刚想到的是水浒里面的好汉
Lucia: What I just thought of was the heroes from "Water Margin."
Jake:对就这个水浒宇宙的完整
Jake: Yes, the completeness of the "Water Margin" universe.
Lucia: great
Lucia: Great.
Shure: 水浒宇宙可还行
Shure: The "Water Margin" universe, huh?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:水浒宇宙
Alice: The "Water Margin" universe.
Lucia: 水浒哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: "Water Margin," hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:没问题吧
Jake: No problem, right?
Alice:没问题
Alice: No problem.
Lucia: 没问题没问题
Lucia: No problem, no problem.
Jake:没问题水
Jake: No problem, water...
Lucia: 写万事皆可宇宙
Lucia: Write "everything is a universe."
Jake:水乎宇宙
Jake: "Water Margin" universe.
Lucia: 都是那两个漫画公司折腾出来的破事
Lucia: It's all those two comic companies' fault.
Lucia: 不过我从我从高中开始看DC和漫威
Lucia: But I've been reading DC and Marvel since high school.
Lucia: 然后一直看
Lucia: And I kept reading.
Lucia: 到现在然后每天都每天都在
Lucia: Until now, and every day, every day...
Lucia: 就是精神
Lucia: Like a mental...
Lucia: 股东
Lucia: Shareholder.
Lucia: 和期待这两个公司破产的边缘摇摆
Lucia: Swaying on the edge of hoping these two companies go bankrupt.
Lucia: 因为我觉得你们写出来这种狗屎故事
Lucia: Because I think the stories you write are such crap.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 要不然还是别编了哈哈哈
Lucia: Maybe you should just stop writing, hahaha.
Jake:还有一个
Jake: There's another one.
Jake:这个 197
Jake: This, 197.
Jake:这个数字代表1970年
Jake: This number represents the year 1970.
Jake:那一年首次庆祝的地球日
Jake: The first Earth Day was celebrated that year.
Jake:这个数字具有重要的历史和纪念意义
Jake: This number has important historical and commemorative significance.
Jake:看对不对
Jake: See if that's correct.
Lucia: 我估计他就是算准了
Lucia: I guess he just calculated it.
Lucia: 有一些东西你也不能确定
Lucia: There are some things you can't be sure of.
Lucia: 所以他就在这乱说
Lucia: So he just makes stuff up.
Jake:对他就是乱说
Jake: Yeah, he just makes stuff up.
Jake:这个确实是真的 1970年
Jake: This one is true though, 1970.
Shure: 怎么跟大张伟那死动静似的
Shure: How does it sound like Da Zhang Wei's nonsense?
Shure: 把这个大屏幕打开然后
Shure: Turn on this big screen and then
Jake:然后
Jake: And then
Shure: 想想地球日的题目
Shure: Think about the Earth Day theme
Jake:行啊来吧
Jake: Alright, let's do it
Jake:谁有那什么账号
Jake: Who has that account?
Shure: 哎把那俩遥控器给我去
Shure: Hey, give me those two remotes
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Jake:遥控器是在这
Jake: The remote is here
Jake:所以他开了是吧
Jake: So he turned it on, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈不是问大家132为什么是回本书
Lucia: Hahaha, no, ask everyone why 132 is a return book
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Hmm, oh
Jake:问问他是吧
Jake: Ask him, right?
Lucia: 对就把这个作
Lucia: Yes, make this a topic
Jake:我再问一下
Jake: I'll ask again
Lucia: 不是把这个作为一个题目
Lucia: No, make this a topic
Jake:哈哈哈让大家乱编
Jake: Hahaha, let everyone make up stuff
Lucia: 对对对我可能会被全场人打神经病
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, I might be called crazy by everyone
Jake:人均GBT哈哈哈
Jake: Everyone's GBT, hahaha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:人均GBT
Jake: Everyone's GBT
Jake:弱智娃
Jake: Dumb kid
Lucia: 弱智吧哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Dumb, hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:我们要不就弱智娃
Jake: Why don't we just use "dumb kid"
Jake:题目里面抽几个得了哈哈哈
Jake: Pick a few from the topic, haha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 我又想起来昨天那个北京是什么
Lucia: I just remembered what happened yesterday in Beijing
Lucia: 我说直辖市
Lucia: I said it was a municipality
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈我没看到他指的那辆车
Lucia: Haha, I didn't see the car he was pointing at
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia: 我以为你
Lucia: I thought you
Jake:太典型了这个哈哈
Jake: This is so typical, haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 我以为你真的在正儿八经的问
Lucia: I thought you were seriously asking.
Jake:哈正儿八经的
Jake: Haha, seriously asking.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 所以对
Lucia: So yeah.
Jake:问北京市
Jake: Asking about Beijing.
Lucia: 然后我就没有感觉到这个问题的意义
Lucia: Then I didn't see the point of the question.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:就送来一个正确的回答
Jake: Just gave a correct answer.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 对啊这个肯定不会出错吧
Lucia: Yeah, this definitely wouldn't be wrong, right?
Lucia: 谁知道你问的是车呢
Lucia: Who knew you were asking about cars?
Jake:所以试试
Jake: So try it.
Jake:吧那个车
Jake: That car.
Lucia: 不知道不了解
Lucia: Don't know, no idea.
Lucia: 就是有一个车牌子叫北京好像
Lucia: There is a car brand called Beijing, I think.
Lucia: 汽车厂牌
Lucia: A car manufacturer.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake:那个什么陨石为什么每次都精 准的砸到陨石坑里
Jake: Why do meteors always hit the craters so precisely?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 现在是冷笑话时间了是
Lucia: Is it cold joke time now?
Alice:hahahaha
Alice: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈太蠢了
Shure: Haha, so dumb.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is that?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 哎呦我受不了了
Shure: Oh, I can't take it.